good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our 2020
2021 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture is supported
by the uva integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it is my privilege and my honor today to welcome
our speaker dr giselle petzinger associate
professor of neurology from the keck school of
medicine at the university of southern california
dr petzinger is a physician and board certified
neurologist specializing in the care of patients
suffering from parkinson's disease she divides
her time between clinical care for patients
and active laboratory research the primary
focus of dr petzinger's laboratory is to better
understand how to promote brain repair resulting
from neurological syndromes or following injury
and should translate these into new therapeutic
treatments dr petzinger has been involved with
numerous federally funded research projects from
the nih the department of defense and notably
she serves as the principal investigator on the
u.s army research grant entitled behavioral and
pharmacological enhancement of neuroplasticity
and basal ganglia of the mptp lesioned mouse and
in non-human primates dr petzinger's lecture today
is entitled investigating mechanisms of exercise
induced neuroplasticity in cognitive motor systems
in parkinson's disease translational studies and
animal models of pd to clinical research as
always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube if you're watching by
youtube thank you so much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions for dr
petzinger via the chat feature in their zoom
sessions i'll synthesize these questions and i'll
ask them on your behalf in the last 10 minutes or
so of the lecture and with that welcome giselle
we are so excited to hear your lecture excellent
well thank you so much i'm thrilled to be here
and thank you uh dr van horn for the invitation
to participate in the seminar series um so i get
to talk about something that's obviously near and
dear to my heart which is parkinson's disease um
i'm going to just go through really quickly what
we're going to try to get through in this hour i'm
leaving 10 minutes for some questions at the end
i'm going to introduce parkins disease and then
talk about the field of neural rehabilitation and
how that was brought to the field of parkinson's
um we'll then talk about uh neuroplasticity in
the context of exercise and use our animal models
as an example of understanding these mechanisms
we're then dive into a very particular problem in
parkinson's and that is cognitive problems and how
exercise may be helping that and then we'll get
into some mechanisms at the end that we're uh
basically continuing to investigate and are part
of our current study so parkinson's disease is
considered a neurodegenerative disorder and what
that means is that there is an area of cell loss
what i'm showing here is a normal brain in a
parkinson's brain and what we're pointing here
is the substantia [ __ ] pars compacta which are
um contain melanin so you can see them as a dark
matter in the in the midbrain and you can see
these tracks that go up and reach into uh what's
called the basal ganglia the caudate putamen and
in parkinson's disease we know that we lose about
60 percent of cells 80 of dopamine which starts
leading to the problems that we see clinically
uh parkinson's is characteristically thought of
as a motor problem and what i mean by motor i mean
things like gate and balance dysfunction slowness
uh tremor is not necessary although people often
think about parkinson's as tremor but certainly
not necessary probably the most important thing
though is gate balance and slowness but we also
touch upon some of the non-motor features as it's
relevant to some of the studies that we're doing
and the big one that i'm going to spend time
talking about is something called cognitive
impairment i'm just going to point out the
cognitive impairment um in terms of dementia uh
alzheimer's is the most common form of dementia
the second probably is vascular the third is
parkinson's disease uh cognitive impairment
are is actually very common in park disease and
can be seen um in about 30 30 to 40 percent of
people within the first few years of what we call
mild cognitive parent uh common question people
ask how common is parkinson's well it's one in a
hundred one in a hundred uh individuals over the
age of fifty prevalence is about a million in
north america so moving on um let's talk about
uh another aspect of parkinson's disease that is
not as well uh recognized or at least not thought
about it but it's going to be very relevant
for the talk that i'm about to give because
one of the challenges that we had and i'm going
to kind of walk you through what we went through
initially when we were thinking about uh what we
say exercise induced neuroplasticity um you know
the idea was that we were very interested in
thinking about it as a circuit change right so
obviously people get interested in knowing what
it does for cells for sure but the idea here was
that parkinson's disease is actually more than a
cell problem and that's the other thing to really
uh emphasize as we move forward and i'm just
showing you as an example two particular circuits
these particular circuits called the motor
or somatic motor somatosensory circuit and
the prefrontal striatal circuit or both circuits
that are involved for example in motor movement
and the reason i'm pointing them out is
what people don't understand or realize
is that this particular circuit the middle circuit
in yellow is another term another term we use
for this circuit is called the automatic circuit
this is a circuit that's practiced that over time
becomes um obviously better stronger connections
that actually allows us to move through space
without having to think about it um but we
also have this other circuit that is involved
in processing um movement through space it's
also used for dual tasking this is coming a
circuit coming from the prefrontal cortex of
the basal ganglia and this allows me to update
information about moving movement through space
i'm highlighting this just to keep in mind as we
move forward and think about what we're doing with
exercise the idea is that in parkinson's disease
people actually have deficits the bigger deficits
is in this automatic circuit so people start
requiring more demand on this prefrontal cognitive
so a lot of what parkinson's patients undergo
when they're suffering from from this slowness is
really a problem in automaticity meaning they lose
automatic movements so they look and appear slow
and they have a higher demand on this cognitive
process now this is going to come up as i said
again in our discussion and the reason this is so
important is that this is one of the reasons
why people think there could be some early
cognitive changes obviously don't mean depletion
could be contributing to this but there is this
other idea that maybe uh you know with this higher
dependency on this prefrontal cognitive circuitry
maybe there's some sort of saturation that is
making these patients more vulnerable okay so
to take home point here is obviously we know
parkinson's disease is fundamentally involved
in as a neurodegenerative disease with dopamine
cell loss etc what i want to again take home
point it's also a circuit problem and so this
is going to be important as we move forward
now the the next slide i'm showing you is kind of
the idea of something that we're all appreciative
of which is uh called um neuroplasticity and this
occurred in the decade of the brain where people
were recognizing the importance of neurogenesis
that was ongoing as even in aging um and also um
basically the idea that experiences that we
um we have in our day-to-day life impact uh
how our circuits are formed and we're going
to highlight some specific ideas of that term
again and and we're going to come back to these
terms but i'm going to define them a couple ways
because these are the sorts of ways that we think
about neuroplasticity in the brain i think the
first point to make is very important and that is
fundamentally it is how connections have formed
brain reorganizes itself forming new neural
connections that are happening through life
that itself is a natural aspect of what
we call neuroplasticity circuit formation
the other thing to keep in mind is fundamentally
this is happening at the level of a synapse
so we're thinking about synaptic structure and
function because both of them are relevant when
we think about plasticity the other thing that's
also important to keep in mind and this comes up
when we think about things about uh how things
are changing in relationships to other parts of
the brain which is something called homeostasis
which is that neuroplasticity also probably
underlies aspects of the brain trying to reach
a new normal so if there's one area of the brain
that's injured there's another brain that's part
of the brain that may be taking up the slack
i would argue that what i just described with
parkins disease is an example of that so they lose
automaticity they have to think more about moving
in space and that's a form of homeostasis okay
the last two points are going to be particularly
relevant when we talk about exercise because again
very fundamentally neuroplasticity is the
way that we encode experiences it's the
way we code new behaviors and in essence it's a
way that the damaged brain uh we can basically
have the areas of damage um recover in response to
rehabilitation and the field that really took that
took uh that notion and really uh began to use it
practically in humans really comes from the spinal
cord injury field and actually the stroke field
so parkinson's disease came much later to this
idea and by later i mean in the last 15 years so
this is an another slide i i think it's you know
just a good slide to remind ourselves
that obviously we recognize how important
experience dependent or plasticity is in
children we see these in athletes so they
you know at the the top form of fluid moving
through space but really where we're at now
in the field very much so is the idea that we
can harness these experiences and provide them
in a very deliberate way to try to um kind
of direct plasticity so we're trying to see
areas of the brain that we think are
compromised how can we use exercise to as
a repair system and importantly understand those
mechanisms that underlie that repair so we can
tap into that as well so when when um i started
getting into the field uh so again this would be
um the early 2000 that long ago it doesn't seem
that long ago but it's been that long um basically
one of the things that we started seeing in
parkinson's was this idea um that we could do more
tapping into gate and balance problems and so most
of the original work from parkinson's really came
at trying to recover gait imbalance and um
the reason i s i'm saying that is because i
wanted to again the idea of experience that these
physical therapists and these particular exercises
that were being delivered were really trying to
tap into some of the more fundamental points of
parkinson's and um this approach to the field that
we had was very different um i'm gonna i'm going
to juxtapose it to the to the aging field aging
field which we'll talk about in just a second was
more interested in aerobic exercise but because of
parkinson's disease the fundamental problem being
with gait imbalance you know if we're thinking
about neuroplasticity then you go after recovery
of that through these different types of exercises
and one of the things that comes up about it often
about thinking about all these different exercises
again what do they have in common and why do many
of these different type of exercises show the
same benefits with gait imbalance which is what
they've done um and one of the ideas that
started coming out of this discussion about
all these different types of practices that could
lead to improvement was that they had basically a
practice learning skill modality fundamentally
patients are getting repetition they're getting
feedback to get better at gain imbalance and
so that what's coming out of the field then
and kind of getting a an understanding of this
approach is in exercise for parkinson's disease
we were very much skill goal oriented right out
of the gate um and we saw some pretty amazing
improvements and i'm going to just show you
an example so this is a typical patient with
parkinson's and the way again we characterize
it is slowness and gait and balance you can see
he's taking a very short steps and in just a
moment here's going to take even tinier steps
um we call this a context dependency problem
that they have the idea that once they change
even the flooring it gets very hard for them
to to think about how to get through that and
so the steps actually get slower um and so this
is an example of an individual who went through
a gait imbalance training this was no change in
medication at all and so this sort of response
is what basically the literature showed that with
practice particularly focused on gate imbalance
you could definitely get pretty significant gains
in function okay so this is again highlighting
out of the gate what we became very interested in
from the field of parkinson's disease and that is
exercise interventions that were requiring
practice that were specific to the deficit
that were also difficult for the patient in other
words we would progress them through harder and
harder practice um so that they would get better
right and and keeping it complex so this was
interesting because many of these thoughts that
we were describing really were borrowing from
the stroke field of spinal cord injury field
we're all talking the same language which is
the idea of motor learning so we were coming at it
really from kind of a motor learning point of view
um and and so when we were trying to conceptualize
how are we going to study this and parkinson's in
animal models right so we're now taking what
we're learning from humans and we're thinking
okay what's the specific question we're going
to ask now about what why these behaviors are
better fundamentally we started with the idea of
learning and and we talked about that already so
the idea of learning of course is going to happen
right at a synapse so we became very interested in
really tackling this question do we see
evidence for synaptic changes synaptic
plasticity in the basal ganglia right and then
the second factor not a small factor was kind of
all those other things that are beneficial
coming in from from the body to the brain
right and and the aerobic field was really taking
off on this where the idea is that blood flow
just you know get your get your heart
rate up get you know your body in shape
and all these factors would somehow make it to the
brain and then your brain would be better so we
recognized that there were sort of
these juxtaposed ideas that were coming
uh you know in the field of exercise and we
were trying to reconcile that in our in our
brain about what does this really mean and uh
and so the idea we we had come up with was that
the idea is that something is happening very
locally within the brain in those areas that
are having problems deficits basic angle is an
as an example that right i pointed out about
problems in the automatic circuit as an
example prefrontal circuit is an example
but at the same time these factors that may be
coming in from the periphery may be providing the
environment right so that if this repair is going
to happen synaptically what may be coming in from
the periphery is support nor you know so a type
of um fertilizer if you will right that may be
supporting these types of synaptic changes okay so
this is sort of another way to think about it so
we were we were sort of here on the left with
parkinson's much more skill and here's the heart
field right the idea of the the aerobic exercise
field the aging field that was really tapping into
the idea of blood flow all right so we'll get
back to that in just a minute i'm just going
to go on and we're going to talk about animal
models our little joke here on translational and
hipaa hipper protection for our mouse and our
people so here we have um an example of some
work that we have done again this is in uh 2007 um
basically we started off with an mptp rodent model
now there's a lot of confusion in the field about
how you design some studies with mptp models
one of the things i wanted to point out
here because this is going to be important
um we know after we give mptp so if we lesion an
animal we know when all that cell death is going
to be done we actually know that by five days
cell death is gone so if i'm using an intervention
out here which is what we did we're not looking
at neuro protection this is not a neuro protection
study at all this at this point is looking at
a model in which there's already cell death
and there's dopamine depletion so think about it
this way i'm looking at a parkinson's patient okay
so i'm not trying to prevent cell death i'm
trying to see in this animal model that is
already have deficits can i do anything to that
brain now so this would be a nor restorative model
okay so with that in mind we have these two groups
of animals these are our parkinsonian mptp animal
that i said have completed cell death so we
know already they're parkinsonian and here's
our healthy control and we basically have them
in exercise and no exercise groups on both sides
okay and so this is basically the original um
this is some of the original treadmill work
that we did and um you can see that these animals
actually get up to pretty high speeds now you can
argue that most of this is aerobic which is true
um but um if you don't know a mouse obviously
most mice are not running in a direction like
this and certainly not heading towards the wall
so we did feel that this angle obviously had to
have some prefrontal circuits activated here to
be able to attend to the task and concentrate on
what it needed to do to make sure it didn't hit
the back end and get sacked so there is aspects of
cognitive uh certainly intentional control um what
i want to show you here is basically the original
paper that was really a paper focused on neural
restoration there had been already one other
paper out there using a similar model to us who
had looked at nerve protection so again just to
make these uh juxtapose these two different ideas
in this case they're parkinsonians so what
i'm looking for is improvement in behavior
and what we see here is after we have had the
animals run for about four weeks weekends off
we see that these animals get better so here
in the dark uh black is sailing here's the
mptp animal and so here we see an exercise group
that parkinsonian animals in fact get better and
it's kind of like no surprise now if i practice
skill i'm going to get better at skill and we're
certainly able to demonstrate that in a mouse
but what was surprising to us were a couple other
things that came out of that and one of the things
that came out that we thought was so important
was when we looked at total dopamine levels so we
talked about dopamine and how dopamine is depleted
right so we can see that in this mptv animal
here's the black bar here's your dopamine
depletion our parkinsonian animal and our
control you can see it's quite depleted in
the mouse what's surprising to us though was when
we saw exercise uh so this is after the animal
finished exercise we didn't see any recovery of
dopamine and that becomes very important because
it kind of helped us kind of secure our thoughts
which was we were interested in circuitry we were
interested to know something downstream
what was happening downstream that may be
relevant for driving these effects because
the tendency was to think if i am improving
and parkinson's i must have some element of
neurogenesis or i must have some sort of dopamine
recovery and that is not the case at least not
in this type of experimental design and that
again pulled us out of the niagara and now into
the circuitry to start looking more specifically
what's happening there now what we were able to
do though is we were able to look at release of
doping and this is a basically a physiological
approach called voltometry all i'm showing here
is a slice of a brain and all these different
areas of places where we introduce the needle
and we excite that area and look for dopamine
release take home point is way down here what
we're showing you here is what's in hatched or
exercised animals in all those different positions
i'm showing you in the basal ganglia up here
and in dark gray is a non-exercise you can see
anywhere that i excite i'm getting more doping
release so take home not changing the amount of
dopamine but absolutely changing the properties of
the dopamine meaning that they're being released
the other thing that we saw i'm just going to
slide down to here is to show you that we didn't
see any changes in cell number so no there is
no evidence of neurogenesis with exercise and
we've never seen that in in our model uh basically
there's so what what i'm trying to say is whatever
change that i've shown you so far it's basically
in release properties uh this slide up here it's
just a take-home point to say that we're also
seeing in dark uh gray is our ability to to image
uh the transport of domain which is a reuptake
system and actually the transport system goes
down meaning don't mean it's not being taken back
up in fact it's being left out in the synapse so
this is homeostasis this is a perfect example
of homeostasis and it matches the ideas of
neuroplasticity okay so what else did we learn and
i'll try to move a little quickly here um we also
learned that we were changing domain receptors in
the basal ganglia d2 is a very critical one for
motor control here's your mptp parkinsonian animal
we saw it go up with exercise but more importantly
was being able to translate that into an image and
what we were able to do was use a falapride f-18
phallopride to be able to see whether or not
we had d2 receptor changes within the stratum
and the take-home message as we were so this is
a superimposed pet image with uh an mri image
of a mouse and here we have d2 phallopride um in
red and here we have it in a parkinsonian state
d2 regulation or d2 expression going down and
then with exercise d2 is up we were particularly
interested in using phala pride because rachel
pride which you some people may be familiar with
is actually probably a better measure for dopamine
amount uh and we didn't want to look at domain
amount we were interested specifically on the d2
receptor uh f18 thalapride was a um designed by
a chemist at uc irvine um and he was able to help
us execute the studies so take home point is that
we see release of dopamine and we see an increase
in dopamine receptors although we see no change in
total dopamine levels or cell number we're also
able to replicate this in a much smaller study
in parkinson's patients so that uh study that
we talked about in the very beginning you know
we talked about all these different types
of exercises one of the exercises that we
really got involved in uh which i don't have to
a time to show you pre-post videos of that was
a treadmill study so we basically put patients on
treadmill these were newly diagnosed patients with
parkinson's on no medication at all um because
you and i both know that medication can sometimes
affect some of these tracers so we had patients
on no medication we put them through eight weeks
of exercise and what you're seeing here is a pre
post actually it's a post minus pre d2 scan here's
again superimposed here's your pet scan with d2
here's their mri and this is a super super imposed
pet on on a um mri image just to show you how
sensitive that thalaprite is to the stratum and
here's your this is actually the most important
picture which is 1d what you're seeing in red is a
subtraction of post-exercise from pre-exercise to
show that what we saw in animals was also true in
humans um and so that again showing how important
uh exercise was and actually just changing just
the local dynamics of dopamine within that stratum
so again we're downstream of the nigral system
we're actually within the basal ganglia um another
aspect of neurotransmission that we're interested
in is actually something called glutamate uh for
those of you who study uh synaptic structure and
function you know how important glutamate is in
terms of regulating the functional aspects of the
synapse so i'm just showing you a cartoon drawing
of synapse that is happening within the striatum
so these are going to be glutamatergic inputs
coming in from the cortex so here we have here and
on the postsynaptic side are what we call medium
spiny neurons and that's really what makes up the
bulk of the stratum so i'm showing you a synapse
and what i'm showing you in cartoon image here is
a number of very different important facets
that we saw change within the glutamatergic
system with exercise and one thing we saw is in
mbtp what's interesting and what's been reported
is when dopamine depletion occurs you actually
have a build up of this glutamatergic system
it gets very hypoxidable we call it increased
glutamatergic drive it's aberrant it actually
leads to average behavior so we have in one aspect
we have loss of synapses within the striatum
but in those remaining synapses we have this
buildup of glutamate we see a lot of glutamate
presynaptically we can use em this was how we
looked at that em shows high levels of glutamate
here and postsynaptically we could see a buildup
of glutamate postsynaptically and that's um what
we see here in white um and then with exercise
we saw it normalized so that's the take-home
point glutamate which is typically thought of as
hyperglutamatergic in the parkinsonian state we
saw it normalized with exercise so again further
evidence that in fact we are seeing um homeostatic
changes really so we're driving i'm going to
pull through to get through this some pretty
significant players in terms of neurotransmitters
within the striatum itself and a lot of that work
we ended up taking on into the prefrontal circuit
as well prefrontal cortex in particular and we're
able to replicate a lot of what i just showed you
there in the stratum so another very important
point that people don't realize is here's a
medium spiny neuron right here we've blown this up
and we're going to take a look at this medium
spin on the neuron because what we're particularly
interested in is all these little thorny things
happening off to the side these are synapses and
um and remember again if as i mentioned if you're
interested in plasticity at fundamentally you do
want to get at the level of the synapse and that's
why we do these animal studies so what i'm showing
you here down below is a blown up version of
this just to show you the number of contacts
these medium spinning neurons are as i told you
coming from the cortex the cortical striatal input
is pretty big so is the thalamic striatal input
and basically they provide a glutamatergic tone
on that median spinal neuron i told you that when
dopamine depletion occurs we saw we saw changes in
glutamate neurotransmission i said it went up but
we also see loss of contact so you can see that
so there's actual disintegration if you will we
see loss of synapses within the stratum so that's
such an important point because again i think
one of the issues that often comes up is people
have this idea that everything is happening down
in the midbrain the truth is a lot of the action
is hopping upstream at the level of circuitry and
and so this is again just a perfect example of
why we need to be focused on circuitry in
parkinson's and um also i'm going to just show you
one other uh this is again another medium spinning
neuron this is work done by bill toy in the lab
uh she basically was able to trace a 3d image
looking at these medium-spinning neurons
and what i want to show you to the right is just
examples of animals uh basically a selected uh
cartoon if you will filled cells just to show
you how different the arborization looks of these
cells so here we have a normal animal this is a
medium spiny neuron within this within the stratum
here's an mptp animal this is dopamine depletion
guys look how different that looks right that's
so you can see actually lots of loss of dendritic
garberization right here and here's exercise so
yeah that's pretty important because again it you
know if if everything holds true in the universe
this animal model is telling us how important it
is that we look at circuitry and synapses i'm not
disregarding the importance of dopamine but what
i'm telling you is that this is key because it's
going to give us some new therapeutic angles to
go after okay so um how about counting spines so
this is again more work with from bill toy in
the lab and all i'm trying to show you here is
how we go about doing this this is a golgi stain
of the dorsal stratum the dorsal stratum is within
the basal ganglia it's the most important motor
aspect of the basal ganglia here it is filled with
golgi and so what we can do what bill did really
uh was he basically counted he counted all these
synapses so you can see with exercise we actually
see some increase even in normal animals which is
good to know so you don't need parkinson's to
get benefit from exercise but here we have with
mptp we see some stripping and here we have mptp
exercise and and this paper um came out in 2011
um basically showing evidence for synaptogenesis
taken point then in parkinson's disease we have
not seen neurogenesis and this is a model where
we have created a parkinsonian animal right
it's not a neuroprotective model it's already a
parkinson's animal now when we apply exercise to
that animal what we do see is evidence for repair
homeostasis neuroplasticity and synaptogenesis
we don't talk neurogenesis at least not within
the basal ganglia and [ __ ] not in our pd field
now there are some evidence for hippocampal and
people hear about that neurogenesis but in areas
that we're particularly interested in it's
for us it really is more about synaptogenesis
that we're interested in okay so let's change uh
directions a little bit and let's talk now about
the different types of exercises that we kind
of talked about from the beginning right we said
in the parkinson's field we're coming at it from
skill base we want to get this gate and balance
effect um but the truth is there's a
lot out there about aerobic exercise and
we were interested in understanding does it
matter what i do particularly if i'm interested
in getting at some of these other circuits like
the prefrontal circuit can i tap into that system
because well it's a problem in parkinson's disease
and daniel hostetter in the lab came up with a
really nice way to study this and and by the way
for those who don't know what skill based exercise
this is things like yoga tai chi pretty much any
type of structured exercise that you can think of
and then aerobic exercise we think of as getting
more your heart rate up so this would be examples
of running swimming cycling that sort of thing and
here's just examples of that not the not kind of
unusual examples i don't know we thought that was
kind of cool okay so here we go so the difference
here is we have animals both of these animals
have these running wheels and these wheels are on
motorized rods so they are definitely getting
the aerobic practice without a doubt but the
difference between these different running wheels
as you can see is one has spokes removed and one
does not and and so what we were trying to do here
what what dr holsteiner particularly was trying to
do was try to tap into the idea of how important
is it to be engaged in what you're doing can you
just be running or getting your heart rate up or
having that extra benefit is that something that
could be relevant um and so what he did was he put
those animals through those uh running wheel for
about six weeks and he has uh his background is
being able to do cerebral blood flow mapping he
does that by using this particular dye c c14 iodo
anti-pyrene and so after the animals have finished
exercise he he keeps them uh perfused um with this
dye and um basically after that perfusion is done
this the brain is removed put on on film and we
can do a type of parametric mapping like we do
in humans so this is looking at those two groups
of animals now you can see uh what what dr
schneider did was put a seed in one of those areas
the prefrontal cortex to see what else is being
connected to that area once that area is seeded
and the comparison is again between the non-skill
and the skilled and what was kind of cool about
this was that it seemed to suggest that it did
matter that blood flow seemed to suggest that
yes the more commonly engaged that you're that
you are in the task um you can change at least
uh regional cerebral blood flow and we we believe
that that is a marker of neural activity
that's part of the ongoing studies that we're
doing right now is to begin to understand what is
underlying that effect evidence for angiogenesis
and also um neuronal uh synaptogenesis so back to
this story then um let's talk uh a little bit more
about uh more specifically about aerobic exercise
and what i decided to do um you know so we had
already done some work with skilled exercise and i
given the fact that the aerobic uh exercise field
physically cognitive aging had shown so many
of these incredible effects with um cognition
particularly executive function which is what
we're interested prefrontal cortex is executive
function and memory uh decided to go ahead and
see if we could take a look at that in uh patients
with parkinson's disease and so what we decided to
start off with was just a cross-sectional study so
no intervention just patients that we knew were
already active were recruited into the study
uh this was 48 patients and this is sort of a
breakdown of their age so about 64 years of age
uh slightly higher um more more more men than
females which is more men than women which is
actually very common and parkinson's uh there's
slightly a higher incidence of parkinson's in
men than women it's also easier to recruit men
in general most studies um and then the years
of diagnosis is about 10 10 years of diagnosis we
looked at some aspects of fitness our particular
interest was this one this is a way that we can
look at cardiorespiratory fitness so people talk
about do2max so cardiorespiratory fitness has
a lot of different kinds of ideas behind it
but one idea is that it's sort of reflective of
blood flow as well so it obviously vo2 max is
how well i'm extracting oxygen but people also
use it sort of as a surrogate if you will of how
much blood i'm getting into the brain so i'm i'm
pointing out a couple uh aspects of parkinson's
that we i mentioned before that we're interested
in um i didn't particularly mean to highlight this
but memory memory is definitely one of them uh
so it is uh not just unique to alzheimer's but
we definitely see pd executive function though
i would say is quite big visual spatial so
executive function is a prefrontal system visual
spatial function which is my ability to navigate
through crowds uh attention processing speed all
of these are actually pretty common deficits that
we can see even early in parkinson's disease
and so what we were able to show in this um
there you go oops yeah so i'm just going
to highlight quickly some very uh points
on this particular study i'm
going to show first of all we were
we did take uh in with the mri we were able
to segment the brain and do some free server
analysis with our patients with heart disease
and this is just a cartoon to show a couple areas
that we saw some hits with cardio respiratory
fitness we saw it with thalamus and pallidum
which is a little surprising but i'm going to
show you some data that may explain that and
then we also saw with a couple of these domains
so we saw again in this cross-sectional study
a very significant association between executive
function episodic memory and visual spatial
so it is lining up with what the reporting
in aging um what's different for us is uh
the uh alzheimer's field reports in structural
changes in the hippocampus um so they see a
relationship between cardiorespiratory fitness and
the hippocampus and prefrontal and we saw it uh in
the thalamus and the pallidum and again i'll tell
you why we think that is in just a second um the
other point of this paper this paper is hopefully
coming out soon and parkinsonism-related disorders
it's being submitted right now but the point is
what i also want to show is we were able to look
at some mediation analysis here all this is it's
a mediation analysis where we try to see whether
the effects of vo2 on things like episodic memory
or vo2 and executive function can be explained by
uh volumetrics in thalamus and are uh basically we
were able to show that in fact it was explaining
this okay so i mentioned to you that i would say
something about why thalamus it was an unexpected
finding uh so what i'm going to just highlight is
as another paper again uh holsteider dr holshander
our group who had done some studies looking
at exercise um and more particularly uh using
the same blood flow technique um basically able
to show that actually with aerobic exercise we
are seeing uh quite a bit of activation within the
thalamus and there's two areas in particular that
we're seeing changes in the cm and the ventral
lateral aspects these are a particular interest
because actually these areas are very much uh
interconnected with the prefrontal cortex lots of
data out in parkinson's in fact about the lambic
changes that occur uh with cognitive impairment um
so uh stay tuned but yes lots now coming out more
and more on the on how important the thalamus is
and how the thalamus really works
with the prefrontal system um to help
with executive function and the same also is
true for for memory okay so um let me just
keep going so mechanisms that we are interested at
looking at now that we've got some obviously some
interesting data uh i've told you that there was
already a lot published with with um balance and
gate with parkinson's the cognitive field is still
something up for debate it's been mostly studied
in aging but there are a number of studies that
have come out uh two studies particularly aerobic
exercise where they've sung some changes with
ef our study was different because we looked at
cardiorespiratory fitness that hasn't really been
looked at that way uh in our parkinson's disease
but we're seeing uh definitely some association
there so we're excited that we're seeing something
similar to what's been reported in aerobic
exercise as well but the question still remains
um why do we care what what is underlying these
effects how can we better understand that and i'm
just listing you know a couple things that we're
particularly interested in i'm going to point out
uh some very specific factors that we're looking
at obviously neurotrophic factors is way up there
but as i mentioned um you know angiogenesis and
blood flow is also critical for us um uh because
um the some of the original work uh that was done
in animal models where we saw exercise effects on
the brain this is a study that was done by green
l and black back in the 70s basically showed how
important angiogenesis was in animal behavior
so we're trying to look at angiogenesis as well
um so in thinking about that um one of the things
um so let's talk about tropic factors first
we got interested in looking at one particular
cell of the brain that is probably one of the
most important cells that uh is important for
neurotrophic factor delivery and more importantly
for support of neuronal support and this
these are actual astrocytes so what's kind
of cool about the astrocytes is they have
a way not only to tap into blood vessels so
uh all the small capillaries they're lying up
against but they they also have very strong
connections to synapses right and we talked
about how important synapses are so astrocytes
became very important for us because we were
interested to see uh what role they may play
in providing support number one but number two
they're also a venue or a a supplier if you will
of no trophic factors so um one of our graduate
students in the lab began to look at astrocytes
um in uh animals and began to look at them and
these two very specific areas were interested
in the prefrontal cortex in the stratum and
what he was able to show with exercise was this
pretty impressive arborization that's happening
with astrocytes uh just through exercise
the other thing he was able to demonstrate was so
one of the things we knew that astrocytes did um
was not only provide trophic support but
actually provide uh fuel to the synapses
and one important source of fuel believe it or
not um is actually lactate so where does lactate
come from well lactate comes from the periphery
lactate is certainly upregulated with exercise
so we wanted to find a way to see what lactate
what role lactate may play um in this effect of
exercise so to step back for a second if i imagine
that i'm exercising i imagine that i got i have
some lactate build up that's being delivered
to the astrocytes the question is what and how
is astrocytes responding to this so here's the
study that was done by adam lundqvist in the lab
and here are some astrocytes that he put lactate
on up he pulled them from the brain and what we're
showing here is just a number of neurotrophic
factors um that he was able to measure in these
cultures and basically what we're highlighting
here are some big ones gd and f and bdnf are
very commonly described neurotrophic factors
particularly in exercise field as an example
we can see that actually with the administration
of lactate these astrocytes from the brain are
in fact making trophic factors so that is again
as we unders try to understand how synapses are
uh remodeling both functionally and structurally
astrocytes may play a very important role as we
would anticipate given its role in synaptic
structure maintenance and repair i think the
other uh thing that was also um important was
that he repeated the study in a live animal so
the other study was done in culture but he was
able to show when he lacked when he administered
lactate to animals he was also able to and
take out the animal brain again he was able
to replicate what he saw in cell culture which is
an increase here we go these are bdnf and and cntf
gdnf that it is absolutely it's upregulated in
the brain and he was also able to show again in
uh in vivo study that this that we saw a growth
in the astrocytic morphology as well okay so
changing tracks again so here we are understanding
what is causing repair to occur picking one cell
as an important cell astrocytes one possibility
is lactate coming in from the periphery maybe
helping these astrocytes not only provide
fuel so astrocytes can deliver lactate
to the cell but also play a role in trophic
support how about the immune system we tend
to think about the immune system as bad obviously
with covid going on we all think of it as bad but
it turns out as you know that everything has
good parts and bad parts so we were interested
in looking at the good parts of the immune system
and what we decided to do was first and foremost
was to take a look at whether or not there was any
evidence for immune cells coming into the brain
um i'm going to uh walk you through this kind
of busy slide so bear with me for just a second
first of all we're using the mouse model of
parkinson's again this was work done by brett lund
in our group and one of the questions that we were
trying to ask was uh looking at another important
cell within the brain it's called microglia
it's equivalent in the periphery are called
mononuclear cells so while the majority of so in
microglia another cell that can provide trophic
support it's also very important for repair
it is the innate immune system of the brain
um what's kind of cool about this is that
people for a long time felt that there was
um basically some immune privilege in the brain
meaning that there was no interchange with the
periphery um but that now that idea has now
gone away and now people are accepting yes
actually there are some peripheral mononuclear
cells that can go into the brain and change
phenotype to become now look like microglial
cells so the reason we did this study was we
were interested in understanding was there
any contribution from the immune system and
particularly cells coming in from the periphery to
the brain in an exercise animal taken point is yes
and the way this was done was basically looking at
surface markers that we knew existed on peripheral
mononuclear cells and we can use what's called a
facts analysis to actually measure the presence
of these cells and so what you're seeing
circled in red is our analysis looking for the
presence of these cells now in the brain the
way we do that is we're going to have these four
different groups of animals after they complete
their tasks we're going to take the brain out this
is taking the whole brain out and we're going to
start we emulsif we we separate out cells and we
start looking for these purple mononuclear cells
which i said we can track because we have we know
what to look for on the cell surface and i'm going
to show you here here's an mptp animal that has
gone through no exercise the same model they're
going through the treadmill just like i showed you
from the very beginning so basically four weeks of
exercise or pardon me up to six weeks of exercise
so here's mptp no exercise here we go two weeks
boom coming in from the periphery guys six weeks
boom even more isn't that cool that's wild yeah so
here and this is just quantitative so yes it does
seem like peripheral mononuclear cells can come
into the periphery and so the whole idea that and
we toy with this not uncommonly i mean what does
alterations of blood-brain barrier really mean you
know again you know nothing is dichotomous i mean
it's not all bad or you know it's so the idea is
that there's there could be some important aspects
of changes in the barber barrier and this in this
case some aspects that are actually allowing
mononuclear cells to come in now you would ask
yourself are you doing something bad to this brain
and the answer to that was also answered in the
next slide so what we're showing here in a little
cute cartoon here is basically this is the this is
the exercise non-exercise and what we looked at
were both pro and anti-inflammatory markers and
these are the pro-inflammatory and these are
anti-inflammatory we wanted to know whether in
general the cells that i just showed you in that
brain we can extract them and then we actually
um cause them we activate them we can use
something uh anagen to basically activate
these cells to start secreting what they
what they typically make to bring it out more
and so what we're able to demonstrate in these
same cells was an increase in neurotrophic factors
and anti-inflammatory so it's an anti-inflammatory
markers here's also showing that these ones that
would be considered prolimiter are down regulated
so take home point is in the mptp exercise in
white we're seeing clear evidence that these cells
coming in are not bad these cells that are coming
in with exercise are providing some trophic
support um okay so i'm gonna um end right there
with some take-home points um that um we that we
talked about at this at this uh seminar and then
i'll also talk very briefly what we're planning to
do where we're going from here but basically the
idea is absolutely multiple types of exercise seem
to be important but maybe for different reasons so
i i think the idea that um obviously we're still
interested in aerobic exercise but skill exercise
um still plays a role here and it may be that
skilled exercise may be tapping into more
motor aspects of movement if you will um
and that aerobic may be more cognitive um
i think the other thing when we talk about
looking for evidence for plasticity i
i hope i try to convince you that yes i mean we do
think whatever the effects of these exercises are
on in parkinson's we very much think that it's
happening within a circuit um and again not to
dismiss the importance of dopamine but we do feel
that with the animal data it's strongly supporting
synaptic restructuring um and both morphological
and functional changes that we're seeing
in terms of what's driving this these are studies
that are ongoing right now we are currently
um looking at a number of different immune factors
in our a big dod study that's going on right now
department of defense this is actually with jack
van van horn and siva uh vancadish who are helping
us to look at structural and functional changes
in imaging over an 18-month period baseline and
in 18 months and we're also looking to see how
this relates to some immune factors that we've
looked at in in animals we're going to see how
that relates to the humans um we're also looking
for uh changes in uh and a number of
neurotrophic factors as well so um i'm gonna
end with this slide um i just want to remind you
it takes a village i'm fortunate very fortunate
um that i get to work with a lot of really
great people this is a big list uh and again
we just joined is siva and jack van horn duck
vent horn which was thrilled uh to partner with
uh at university of virginia and then uh michael
jackwick a pi uh co-pi here at usc don scheisser
ucsd dan holstein who i mentioned as well who's
uh basically here at usc a big co-pi of this study
and brett lund here with a lot of the immune
data um also adam lundqvist who did a lot of
the work with the astrocytes has been particularly
important and that we have another grad student
aaron donahue who will be helping quite a bit
with the immune factors um i thank you so much
for allowing me to present this as i said i i
work with an amazing team and just to emphasize
again it's all about finding a great team to work
with i can't emphasize that enough and uh in any
event i'm happy to take any questions thank you so
much giselle that was a fantastic tour de force of
all the current thinking in parkinson's disease
research um a couple of questions so i was really
intrigued uh i've always been intrigued about
uh the role of the thalamus here um it just it
is the sort of the router of the brain and
uh given the emphasis you put on circuitry
um i'm kind of curious a little more about the
thalamus um whether or not these are you know
what are these um nuclei that are the ones
that you're focused on or the ones that like
the results have borne out are do these tend
to be more association nuclei relay nuclei are
they interlaminar um do you have a sense you know
right now not not really we actually i mean that
data was actually surprised to us we have not
really paid attention too much of the thalamus
it was because of this the findings that we
just showed you and then looking back at some
of the work that daniel host under did that we
began to see oh my gosh there's a lot there that
we need to start looking at i mean i think um
people certainly appreciate the role more so now
um although mike would argue that that that people
have been looking at it from for a number of years
but um its ruling cognition i would still say is
relatively new there's not that much out there
on it um so you know all those those are all great
questions we simply don't know i i can say though
that um you know again if you look at some of the
imaging data out there not not a lot of functional
imaging but structural imaging um that there are
definitely reports of at least volume loss there
and um both regionally and uh globally in in the
thalamus um i would also say that you know prior
to um most of the work in thalamus as you may
already know has really been focused on motor
so again cognition is going to be kind of
relatively new and not that much out there
so i think hopefully you and and steve are going
to help us with that answer that question right
um one thing which you you touched on it in
a couple of different places in your talk
is um that bdnf uh got players to have some direct
relationship to exercise uh gdnf as well and other
neurotrophic factors and i'm curious about their
role in cognition um kind of more specifically
but then also how specific are some of these
effects in parkinson's disease and are there
other implications for other neurodegenerative
disorders yeah i mean i think again that's that
is a great question i mean i think first of all
people have looked at bdnf um in uh parkinson's
models and have definitely seen some changes in
bdnf expression within the stridom i think one of
the questions that often comes up is how relevant
is bdnf expression in the periphery particularly
just measuring it and i think that's a little
bit why we got interested in looking at cells
um because the idea is that bdnf may not cross
and there's but but for example immune cells may
and that may be the more important driver i
think the other thing is what cells may be
making locally that may be important here as well
and again that's the asset side and the microglia
both of which could contribute to to know some
neurotrophic factor support um i think the
question though that comes up is you know kind of
how specific regionally specific are these effects
um we don't know i mean we we'd like to think
that they are originally specific we like to think
that some of this may be uh circuit specific um
maybe because of blood flow you know that changes
fundamental changes in angiogenesis
is really what's driving these effects
so wherever you're seeing angiogenesis is where
most of these effects are happening we believe
and and we believe that because um one thing that
i i didn't get a chance to show was that um we
are seeing some transcript expression from from um
transcripts that are important in in angiogenesis
um and uh neurotropic factor expression that
are coming from neurons so um the the idea that
the neurons that are being activated through the
process of whatever you're doing let's say running
or you know processing information the idea that
neuronal activation may be driving some of these
circuit specific effects so the periphery isn't
creating it it's the actual use of the brain how
you're using your brain if you will the fact
that i'm being more cognitively aware of what
i'm doing and again just to point to the very
specific example that i showed you with daniel
where you know clearly these two animals were
both aerobically challenged but the idea that
one animal was actually much more engaged can
actually change blood circuitry right so at
least by the by by that particular method suggests
that there may be something about exactly what we
said how i'm using my brain how engaged i am
that that may influence some of these effects
how transferable are the uh results
you're finding in mice to humans
you know that's a great question you know so i as
you can see i'm a big animal believer and i often
find you know you you you know you it's really
all about the question and and the limitations
of your model and understanding your model quite
a bit we've i've worked in the model for a very
long time so you know we're not in any way shape
or form saying that this is parkinson's disease
but what i think it does is it really gives us an
example of uh plasticity and and we've certainly
been able to demonstrate that in an animal right
and and show that um again with very little
changes and don't mean you're already getting
quite a bit of downstream activation happening
and uh we've been pretty fortunate in being able
to replicate some of these findings as you can see
for example d2 uh we were able to replicate that
in humans and that was the first study of that
was in an animal an amputee an mptp mouse that's
how we learned that that wasn't human that was
an animal the second thing how we learned it we
learned you know is i talked about this increased
release of dopamine that was just replicated by
john stossel at university of british columbia
he actually used um i think he did use recopy
to demonstrate that there was more dopamine be
released replicating what we first described in
the animal um so i we're hedging our bets that
you know it's a good model when you have a very
specific question that you want to ask um and then
of course you know thinking about how you how you
translate and ask that specific question in humans
but as you know i mean the study we're doing right
now in the dod is totally because of this animal
data including the immune factors you know we're
not looking only at i mean we're not just looking
immune factors in the blood we're looking at
cells for the reasons that we talked about right
the idea that we do think that there could be some
of these cells migrating into the into the brain
and begin and looking to see what they're
making is also very important part of this study
so women are hard to find now is it because
there's just a difference in the diagnostic rate
of parkinson's disease in women or are males just
more likely to want to participate in these things
and if if that's the case have you noticed any
sex differences that might uh be between males
and females with and without pd yeah that that's a
great question so you know in parkinson's there's
a slightly higher incidence of parkinson's and
males and in alzheimer's you know it's just the
reverse it's slightly higher in women um honestly
it's it's pretty common for many studies to
to get more men than women although in our
current dod study were actually about 50 50
i really worked hard to make sure we got a
substantial number of women um in terms of
um you know people have looked at some
gender differences between men and women and
you know there have been some suggestions for
example you know maybe men may be a little bit
more um likelihood for for having more problems
with their parkinson's specifically things like
more cognitive issues as an example but the truth
is it's still relatively understudied um so it's
not a very yeah not as much information out out
there with with parkinson's and women um there's
some but not not that much so hopefully these are
some of the questions that we can try to address
in our group i can say that you know in looking
at some of the you know exercise activities
um we we have women you know we've we've been
looking at a lot of different parameters of
exercise including intensity and you know um
again this is an exercise group that we're
looking at and i was curious uh because we you
know we're seeing some really nice data with some
intensity uh and wearables whether those were all
men and actually it's about 50 50 men and women so
um it's nice to see that our women group
are as active as men i'm not surprised
but uh interestingly some other types of exercise
parameters that i think will be of interest for us
to look at a little bit more closely is back to
that vo2 max as an example of cardio respiratory
fitness one of the things we do know is that a
couple things influence that is the the our our
ability to get that fitness level up as measured
through vo2 max aging will flatten that out a bit
and women tend to be a lot further um just are not
able to get up to that level of cardio respiratory
fitness as men do as measured through vo2 max so
it you start seeing some sex differences um there
um on some of these metrics particularly vo2 max
that's that's actually known um and we hope to be
able to explore that a little bit i'm also hoping
that we're looking at some uh estrogen replacement
questions in this as well where we're going to be
following and tracking that as well with cognition
people have looked at that and there's data both
ways whether or not estrogen is helpful or not
helpful in parkinson's disease for women one final
thing is one thing that's striking about your
presentation is just the different types of data
that you are gathering to look at parkinson's
disease uh whether it's you know at the molecular
level you're looking at these neurotrophic factors
you're looking at pet imaging you're looking at
you know connectivity modeling you know across
spatial and temporal scales how important are
the computational approaches and the kind of the
integration of this data um to being to getting
that comprehensive view of parkinson's disease
yeah i mean i think that's that's well that's why
you're you're joining us jack you're going to help
us with that because i think as you can see you
know it has kind of this puzzle feel to it doesn't
it i mean we've got kind of kind of different
ideas of what's happening in terms of the noon
uh in terms of angiogenesis um even with behavior
and the idea is to try to find a common thread
particularly given the fact that at the end of the
day we are interested in circuit specific effects
and um you know trying to think about that
spatially as well where some of these bigger
effects are happening i think that will be
particularly important because again that
will help us guide the animal data in terms
of where we really need to be diving down and
looking for some of these molecular changes so um
yeah i think a computational approach will help us
without a doubt really focus in and eliminate
things that may be epiphenomenon but are not
nearly as critical as some of these other points
we've talked about that a lot you get a lot of
data but the question is what which ones are the
relevant ones and and uh being able to hone in on
those are certainly helped by a computational
approach fantastic and with that thank you
giselle petzinger from university of southern
california we really appreciate you sharing
your work with us today um what an exciting
project really fantastic talk thank you so much
everybody who's out there listening thank you
so much for for joining us today and we'll look
forward to seeing you next week excellent thanks
so much guys you guys take care bye bye now bye